الاصرار عليه قد يعقد الامه اكثر والتنازل
عنه قد تفهمها المعارضه ضعفا ونقطه محسوبه
على نتنياهو وهو ما حصل بالفعل تراجع
نتنياهو تحت هذا الضغط الكبير عن مشروع
تعديل القضاء حتى وان كان تجميدا وتاجيلا
لكن هذا التراجع لم يكن دون مقابل
ذاكرت وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه انا بن
غفير وافق على تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه
للصيف المقبل حيث دوره الكنيسه القادمه
مقابل تمرير انشاء حرس وطني كما وافق
شركاء بنيامين نتنياهو في الحكومه على
تاجيل البحث في التعديلات القضائيه خطاب
نتنياهو لم يعجب الجانب الاخر تحديدا قاده
الاحتجاجات الذين اكدوا انهم سيبقون في
الشارع لان تراجع نتنياهو هذا كان مجرد
مناوره وفقا لوصفهم
سنعطي فرصه لتمرير التعديلات القضائيه عبر
اجماع واسع لذا قررت تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه لهذه الدوره من الكنيست حتى نصل
لاجماع لدينا اغلبيه في الكنيست تجعلنا
نناقش التعديلات القضائيه وستتم مناقشه
التعديلات القضائيه في الدوره القادمه من
الكنيست اود الاشاره الى اني حصلت على
موافقه اغلبيه زملائي في الحكومه لمنع
الحرب الاهليه عبر الحوار هذه الازمه
تجبرنا على التصرف بمسؤوليه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي هو اكد خلال
خطابه اليوم ان الحكومه لن تقبل بحرب
اهليه واشار الى من وصفهم بالاقليه
المتطرفه التي تريد تمزيق اسرائيل ودعا
قاده الجيش بمواجهه الى مواجهه العصيان
هناك اقليه متطرفه تريد تمزيق اسرائيل
وتسحبنا لحرب اهليه نحن على مسار صدام في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولن نقبل بحرب اهليه
لا اقبل نداءات العصيان واطالب قياده
الجيش والاجهزه الامنيه ان يقفوا في وجه
حركه العصيان اطالب قاده الجيش بمواجهه
ظاهره رفض الخدمه العسكريه الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا يمكن ان يقبل برفض الخدمه
العسكريه
ورغم قرر نتنياهو بتاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي الاسمر بن غفير ان التعليق
مؤقت لنثير اضافه في تصريحات وسط انصاره
ان نتنياهو وعد بان يتم تمرير التعديلات
خلال شهر من الان مشيرا الى انه بحلول هذا
الوقت لن تكون هناك اي حلول وسط وانه سيتم
تنفيذ اراده الاغلبيه